Eric Schlosser's new book reefer madness
is about the underground economy Eric
estimates that the underground economy
is made up or makes up 10% of the total
traditional economy reefer madness
focuses on just three parts of the
underground economy it focuses on
marijuana it focuses on pornography and
the Xplode exploitation of illegal
aliens Eric is the kind of author that
many of us admire he is fearless he goes
after major institutions like the fast
food industry in an earlier time he
would be called a muckraker in our time
he's called a change agent his books are
extremely readable and extremely well
researched eric has been a correspondent
for The Atlantic Monthly since 1996 he's
written for Rolling Stone and he's
written for The New Yorker please join
me in giving Eric Schlosser a South
Florida and Miami Book Fair welcome Eric
[Applause]
well thank you for coming out today on
such a beautiful day to come in here me
and this new book of mine is about the
underground economy and the working of
black markets and I'm sorry to say this
is a very appropriate city to be talking
about this subject
Miami is no longer but was especially in
the late 70s and early 80s the finance
capital of the American black market and
in one of the most incredible stories I
heard about banking here during an
eighth month period in the early 1980s
there was one checking account here in
Miami at one branch of a bank in which
240 million dollars was deposited in
cash and that's not easy to do in eight
months
a million dollars in cash weighs about
200 220 pounds and the bank even though
it loved this one particular customer
put a limit and said it would not accept
more than 2 million in cash a day it was
just too heavy and too much of a hassle
to deal with those Wild West days are
over here for the most part in South
Florida and things have become much more
sophisticated but that's a lot of money
and I became fascinated in the early
1990s with the black market and I became
interested in it because there was so
much talk and there's been so much talk
for the last 20 years about the free
market and about Adam Smith who has who
has emerged as as the great theorist of
the free market but also as one of our
great heroes in the last 20 years and
Adam Smith believed that you could see
the workings of God in the marketplace
and that the buying and selling and what
people wanted to buy and what they
needed to sell was an expression not
only of the divinity
but also of democracy at work and that
whole belief has really taken over that
this country in the last 20 years and I
started thinking about well if the
marketplace is the reflection of the
divinity and is the reflection of
democracy well what about some of these
hidden transactions I mean we've heard
so much in the 90s and particularly
about the internet boom and the
telecommunications boom and all these
mainstream success stories but what
about these other businesses that don't
get the same kind of attention and I
came to believe that looking at the
underground is very important for what
it tells you about the mainstream and
it's my argument in this book reefer
madness that the underground and the
mainstream are inextricably linked and
it's not as though one is entirely black
and what is entirely white there's a
whole series of gray areas and if you
really want to understand a country you
have to see it whole and like the yin
and the yang
the dark and the light the underground
and the mainstream are really connected
now what is the the underground economy
well broadly defined it's all those
economic transactions that are
unrecorded unreported and somehow in
violation of the law now it could be
something very innocuous like paying
your babysitter in cash or paying a
repairman who comes to your house in
cash knowing that that payments never
going to be recorded or it could be
something less innocuous like depositing
two hundred and forty million dollars in
cash from your cocaine trade in a bank
and it's the more serious aspects of the
of the underground economy that I write
about I write about marijuana which is a
major black-market commodity the most
widely used illegal drug in the United
States I write about the exploitation of
illegal immigrants
particularly migrant workers in
California that's black market labor and
I write about the pornography industry
because the pornography industry is a
textbook example of a black market
becoming a mainstream market I mean the
kind of the kind of sexually explicit
material that you now see routinely on
HBO could have gotten you a long prison
sentence 25 or 30 years ago so these
black markets don't know we stay black
markets and certainly gambling is
another example of a black market
becoming a mainstream commodity but I
don't write about that I write about
pornography black markets have always
been with us there's always been
contraband but what's really interesting
is economists agree that it's in the
last 20 years coincidentally as this
free market ideal has been propounded
that the black market the underground
economy in the United States has grown
there are no hard and true numbers
because people are trying very hard to
hide these activities but I used the
estimates of one Austrian economist who
works with the IMF and it seems fairly
conservative and he argues that the
underground economy in the early 1970s
in this country was maybe 2.9 percent of
our total gross domestic product now
it's closer to 10 percent so that would
be about one trillion dollars off the
books with the Internal Revenue Service
in 1998 try to figure out well who's
avoiding federal taxes they estimated
that about 200 billion dollars in
federal taxes was going unpaid that
would be about 1.5 trillion in income
unreported and that does not include
illegal activities so the underground is
big it's been growing and one of the one
of the ways that economists realize that
the Underground was growing is
you know in the 70s there was this whole
belief that we are moving towards a
cashless economy credit cards were this
new invention and and certainly with
electronic banking you would think that
cash would be obsolete it's heavy you
know 200 pounds per million you can lose
it but one of the reason one of the ways
that people discovered that the black
market was growing in the United States
is that the amount of cash in
circulation started growing in the early
1970s and growing enormous Lee and now
the hundred-dollar bill has become the
currency of the black market not only in
the United States but thanks to
globalization worldwide the
hundred-dollar bill is the black market
commodity of the world and what's
remarkable is that three quarters of the
hundred hour bills in circulation are
now overseas floating around and the
United States exports about twenty
billion dollars a year in hundred-dollar
bills so when you're talking about the
underground you're talking about an
enormous enormous cash economy and this
is important it's important not only
just about what it tells you about this
country but it calls into question all
kinds of economic statistics and you
read the paper and it says GNP is 0.1
percent our unemployment is down 0.3
percent and this all seems so scientific
but what do these numbers really mean if
10 percent of the economy may be off the
books or if there are seven eight nine
million illegal immigrants in a black
market labor pool in this country if I
were to date when this free market ideal
really took hold in this country and so
much of this book in looking at the
underground is really questioning the
free market and how much it really
exists I would say that that date when
it officially entered the mainstream in
this country was January of 1981 and the
symbolism to me is important when Ronald
Reagan took off
one of the first things that he did was
he had the portrait of Thomas Jefferson
removed from the Cabinet Room and
instead a portrait of Calvin Coolidge
was put up to replace it now up until
this point Calvin Coolidge was widely
regarded by American historians as one
of the worst presidents the United
States had ever had he was president
during the incredible bubble economy of
the 1920s which led to the huge stock
market crash in 29 he was considered
very narrow and uncaring and basically
is most famous for the quote the chief
business of the American people is
business so Coolidge who had been so
scorned by historians was given a place
of honor by President Reagan and now
there's been a lot of reappraisal and
revisionist history and Coolidge has
become a hero and is depicted heroically
in many new accounts of his life now the
free market and this free market ideal
has become so so fundamental and so
central in our society that it's now
even accepted by the Pentagon which is
remarkable that our military would
embrace any economic view whatsoever the
national security strategy of the United
States is a document that was released
in 2002 and it received a great deal of
attention because it announced our
willingness to stage a pre-emptive war
and that's what most of the media
attention was about but a wonderful
journalist William Finnegan actually
read the thing completely and he came
upon the startling passage in it in
which the Pentagon endorses a certain
specific economic theory and I'm gonna
read you this this is from the
Pentagon's war planning national
security strategy of the United States
September 2000 to quote the concept of
free trade arose as a moral
principal even before it became a pillar
of economics if you can make something
that others value you should be able to
sell it if others make something that
you value you should be able to buy it
this is real freedom and this brings me
to the subject of marijuana because I'm
trying to understand how these markets
work now before talking to you a little
bit about the morality of the market for
marijuana and the morality of freedom as
its applied in marijuana I should be
very blunt and tell you that I have
smoked marijuana and I did inhale and I
did it on more than one occasion but I
am NOT a pot smoker and I have young
kids and I'd really prefer that they not
be pot smokers and there are very very
good reasons why nobody should smoke
marijuana but having said that let's be
honest about what's happening in this
country right now I long ger smoke
marijuana but I use a much much more
dangerous drug and I use it pretty much
on a daily basis and this is my Maricopa
I consume alcohol alcohol is a very
toxic substance you can die of alcohol
poisoning and you know a fair number of
fraternity boys do died of alcohol
poisoning every year in this country
moreover alcohol use has been linked to
two-thirds of all suicides in this
country two-thirds of all cases of
domestic abuse and about 40% of all the
violent crime in the United States is
linked to alcohol abuse plus we have 30
million Americans who are classified as
alcohol abusers and conservatively about
a hundred thousand of
Americans die every year because of
alcohol use I drink another one of my
favorite drugs is even more deadly which
is tobacco and tobacco is responsible
for 400,000 deaths a year and yet the
United States government subsidizes
tobacco production not quite in keeping
with a free market another dangerous
drug that you should be aware of other
class of dangerous drugs is aspirin now
I take aspirin
sometimes after consuming alcohol but
but people who take aspirin should be
aware that it can be a dangerous drug
and as a matter of fact 16,000
American's die every year from taking
various non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
drugs and you shouldn't take tylenol
after alcohol consumption because it can
lead to liver failure now these are
substances that we allow people in this
in this country to consume but there are
real risks involved with them now that
brings me to the subject of marijuana
this enormous black market commodity and
again I'm not encouraging anyone to
smoke marijuana a lot of the pot that's
on the market today is very powerful
it's a powerful psychoactive drug people
who have heart problems should not smoke
marijuana people who are pregnant should
not nobody should operate any heavy
machinery or drive a car
stoned if you're pregnant you shouldn't
take marijuana and if there's any
history of severe mental illness or
schizophrenia you should not smoke pot
but the reality is that marijuana is one
of the least toxic therapeutically
active substances known to man and in
the 5000 years of its recorded use
there's not a single instance of someone
overdosing and dying from marijuana
although many people have tried
scientists have calculated that in order
to have a fatal overdose from marijuana
you would have to smoke a hundred pounds
a minute for 15 minutes and nobody's
come close to that and in addition to
being non-toxic in an acute sense
marijuana has been used as medicine for
thousands of years and this isn't a
radical left-wing hippie point of view
Mara marijuana's usefulness as medicine
has now been acknowledged by such
left-wing groups as the British House of
Lords and marijuana is now prescribed in
the Netherlands and can be obtained
through the National Health Care Service
in the Netherlands and and now in Canada
so you have this one substance that
kills 400,000 people a year in the
United States tobacco which the
government subsidizes and you have this
other substance marijuana which is a
class one scheduled narcotic which means
that according to the government there
is no safe level of use there is no
proper medical use and it's a drug of
high abuse potential and in looking at
marijuana I'm trying to understand how
we came to view this drug this way
what's remarkable is there are more
people in prison for marijuana right now
than at any other time in American
history conservatively anywhere from 30
to 50,000 people in prison for marijuana
crimes and I tell the story of the
marijuana black-market by looking at the
case of Marc young a hippy biker in
Indiana who never was involved in any
violence but for his first marijuana
crime a nonviolent marijuana crime was
given a sentence of life without parole
and sent to one of the most dangerous
federal penitentiaries when you think
about the fact that the typical
convicted murderer in the United
States will spend 11 years behind bars I
really began to wonder well why why did
Mark Young get a life sentence why did
James Montgomery a paraplegic in
Oklahoma who smoked marijuana to relieve
the muscle specific spasticity in his
legs why did he get life +16 for two
ounces of pot found in the pouch on the
back of his wheelchair there are dozens
if not hundreds of offenders who've
gotten life sentences for nonviolent
marijuana crimes and it's remarkable
what can happen to you for possession of
marijuana or for a marijuana crime you
can have all kinds of federal benefits
removed what's what's remarkable is that
if you're convicted of a marijuana
felony which may be possession of an
ounce of marijuana you can have your
federal welfare benefits removed but if
you're convicted of murder or rape or a
child molestation you can still receive
all of those federal benefits so in
looking at marijuana I tried to see well
what is happening in this country and
the marijuana black market is enormous
it may be our largest cash crop and the
laws against marijuana have played a
very large role in making that possible
and in the book I look at Indiana and
the Midwest as being one of our centers
of marijuana production a bushel of corn
now goes for about two dollars and a
bushel of marijuana goes for about
seventy thousand and here you have the
market explaining why some crops are
being grown and others aren't and in
looking at well why why how does a
society come to punish someone more for
a marijuana crime than for killing
someone with a gun the conclusion I came
to is the laws that we have on marijuana
have much less to do with the drug
itself than with a sort of people who
smoke it and the sort of people who use
it in the early part of the 20th century
it was poor Mexicans and then it was
poor blacks and then it was jazz
musicians and again and again you see
this drug associated with
outcasts and racial minorities and
people who the mainstream doesn't like
and after black jazz musicians
it was beatniks and then hippies and now
members of the hip-hop community and you
see the the market for this commodity
being described in very moral terms it
is wrong it is wrong to use marijuana it
is morally wrong in the way that you
know there's not the same condemnation
for having a gin and tonic or a cigar or
a pack of Marlboro this has been a moral
crusade and the people who are in favor
of putting others in jail for life
depict it as a moral crusade and
therefore it's morally right to
intervene in the free market we believe
in the free market on all these other
issues but when it comes to marijuana
the government can intervene on moral
grounds and you know this has been taken
to the height of absurdity I don't know
if you heard but Tommy Chong of the
Cheech and Chong comedy act
is in federal prison right now and he's
in federal prison for endorsing a line
of bongs and through a huge federal
operation involving hundreds of agents
nationwide there was a roundup of bond
manufacturers and they netted Tommy
Chong and attorney general Ashcroft
proudly announced this operation at a
press conference and this was right
before this was right before the war in
Iraq began and I felt proud of my
country I felt very proud because okay
well we don't have mullah omar and we
haven't gotten saddam hussein and we
don't have a sama bin Laden but thank
god tommy chong
Tommy Chong is in jail and again his his
arrest I mean putting Tommy Chong in
prison is gonna you know conservatively
cost us 18 to 20 thousand dollars and
this operation involving hundreds of
agents US Marshals Secret Service men
DEA agents was an extraordinary
expenditure of money now Tommy Chang
must believe that his worst marijuana
paranoid fantasy has actually come true
but he was arrested because he's a
cultural icon of the 60s and this is a
moral crusade against nonconformist and
against the 60s in particular and I
bring this up because I'm now gonna
segue into another part of my book
because in marijuana you see an
aggressive and act of moral intervention
in the free market but when you look at
the exploitation of illegal immigrants
and you look at the black market for
labor in this country and particularly
the mistreatment of migrant workers
which I write about in the book suddenly
free markets got to apply if you want to
see an area where the free market has
been ruthlessly applied it's to the
workers of this country you know minimum
wages they get in the way the workings
of the free market so the minimum wage
has declined by almost 40% in this same
20 year period overtime laws hey if a
worker wants to work 12 or 14 hours who
why should the government prevent it
that's the attitude of the free market
worker safety laws environmental
protections for workers all of these
things have been eliminated or reduced
in the interest of the free market and
in looking at this black market for
labor you see the consequences I spent
time with migrant farm workers in
California they are the poorest poorest
workers in this society and they have
seen their wages cut by 50% in real
terms over the last 20 years in Florida
here the tomato pickers have some of the
tomato pickers have seen their wages cut
by 75% in real terms
for the last 20 years and there's a
terrific group the coalition of
Immokalee Workers who's trying to help
them out so we see an aggressive
intervention in the market when it comes
to our drug laws but when it comes to
ordinary workers and the poorest members
of our society
suddenly the free market is applied
ruthlessly and it's important to look at
California agriculture and migrant
workers because in California the
growers created a system of exploiting
the poorest and weakest in our society
and exploited exploiting illegals that
was unique to California thirty years
ago but is now spreading throughout our
society every industry would like
illegal impoverished workers who maked
mystery in Fast Food Nation I wrote
about how the meatpacking industry has
adopted exactly the same system of
exploitation that California agriculture
has used for decades and now we see that
America's largest employer a Walmart has
been involved we'll see if it's proved
or not but has it's been alleged is
involved in the exploitation of illegal
immigrants some of whom allegedly were
working seven days a week at Mall at
Walmart very long hours very low pay
some being paid paid less than minimum
wage and in Florida agriculture you see
the same thing there have been five
cases of slavery prosecuted in this
state since the mid 1990s and you know
for everyone that's prosecuted there are
many many others that have gone
unreported and this is America in the
year 2003 so when you look very
carefully at the free market as it's
being promulgated in this country it's
really that free and normally is it not
that free but there are enormous
government subsidies going to certain
companies in agriculture we're spending
50 to 20 billion dollars a year in farm
subsidies which are mainly going to a
handful of big agribusiness companies if
you look at the history of this country
how we built our railroads how we built
our interstate highway system how the
internet was created how our aerospace
industry was create
that had nothing to do with the free
market the free market is just being
applied to the poorest and the weakest
members in our society and I'm going to
conclude by reading passage about a
visit I made to some migrant workers in
northern San Diego County where
one-third of the migrants and almost all
of them are illegals from Oaxaca are now
living outdoors that's 7,000 migrant
workers who are homeless and they're
living outdoors with 9,000 of their
family members these are not drug
addicts or junkies or homeless people
these are some of the most hard-working
people you can imagine living outdoors
in shanty towns in northern San Diego
County near some very very wealthy
suburban developments and I'll read you
this passage and then I'd love to hear
questions and and this passage kind of
encapsulate s' my feelings about the
free market ideology we've had the last
20 years and what its implications are
so this is my visit to an encampment of
migrant workers in northern San Diego
County at the end of a driveway near a
chain-link fence I met a young Mishka
Indian from Oaxaca who lived in one of
these encampments his name was Francisco
and he was 18 years old he looked deeply
exhausted he had just picked
strawberries for 12 hours at a nearby
farm I asked what he thought of his boss
not bad he said politely the previous
year Francisco had picked strawberries
from April until July he had saved 800
hours during that period and had wired
all of it to his mother and who his
father in the village of San Sebastian
TECA max waka in Oaxaca
this was Francisco's second season in
the fields but he hadn't gotten to see
much of San Diego County he was too
afraid of getting caught by the AI NS
his days were spent at the farm his
nights at this encampment he picked
strawberries six days a week sometimes
seven for 10 to 12 hours a day when
there's work France
go said you have to work every morning
he woke up at around 4:30 and walked
half an hour to reach the fields at dusk
13:00 tired men and dirty work clothes
approached us they were all from
Francisco's village they work together
at this farm and stayed at night at the
same encampment they knew one another's
families back home and tried to look
after one another back here here the
oldest was 43 and the youngest looked
about 15 all of these men were illegals
all of them were sick with coughs but
none of them dared to see a doctor as
the Sun dropped behind the hills clouds
of mosquitoes descended and yet these
migrants seemed too tired to notice they
lay on their backs on their sides
resting on this hard ground as though it
were a sofa Francisco offered to show me
their encampment we squeezed through a
hole in the chain-link fence and through
gaps and rusting barbed wire and then
climbed a winding path and closed by
tall bushes it felt like a medieval maze
as we neared the camp
I noticed beer cans and food wrappers
littering the ground we came upon the
first Shack short and low more like a
tent just silver trash bags draped over
a wooden frame a little farther up the
paths - three more shacks in a small
clearing they were built of plywood and
camouflaged branches and leaves had been
piled on their roofs the landowner
didn't know that these migrants lived
here and their encampment would be
difficult to find these migrants were
hiding out like criminals or Vietcong
garbage was everywhere Francisco pointed
to his Shack which was five feet high
five feet wide and seven feet long he
shared it with two other men he had a
good blanket but when it rained at night
the roof leaked and the men would have
to go to work
soaking wet the next day and dry off in
the Sun
Francisco had never lived this way
before coming to San Diego at home in
Oaxaca he always slept in a bed
beyond the sheds bushes crowded the
paths again and then it reached another
clearing where two battered lawn chairs
had been placed at the edge of the hill
there was a wonderful view of Strawberry
Fields new houses and the lights of the
freeway in the distance driving back to
my motel that night I thought about the
people of Orange County one of the
richest County in the nation big on
family values yet bankrupt now from
financial speculation unwilling to raise
taxes to pay for their own children's
education unwilling to pay off their
debts whining about the injustice of it
and blaming all of their problems all of
their problems on illegal immigrants and
I thought about Francisco their bogeyman
their scapegoat working ten hours a day
at one of the hardest jobs imaginable
and sleeping on the ground every night
for months so that he could save money
and send it home to his parents we've
been told for years now to bow down
before the market we have placed our
faith in the laws of supply and demand
what has been forgotten or ignored is
that the market rewards only efficiency
every other human value gets in its way
the market will drive wages down like
water until they reach the lowest
possible level today that level is being
set not in Washington DC or in New York
City or in Sacramento but in the fields
of Baja California and the mountain
villages of Oaxaca that level is about
$5 a day it's the going wage in Oaxaca
no deity that men have ever worshiped is
more ruthless and more Hollow than the
free market unchecked and there is no
reason why shanty towns should not
appear
on the outskirts of every American city
all those who now consider themselves
devotees of the free market should take
a good look at what is happening in
California left to its own devices the
free market always seeks a workforce
that is hungry desperate and cheap a
workforce that is anything but free
[Applause]
thank you very much and that's my rant
and I'm glad to take any questions you
might have
lightning lecture until a few years ago
I had no idea that slavery cases were
still prosecuted in the 20th century I
actually met a lawyer who was actually
the first person to successfully
prosecute one of those cases since the
19th century and I was just wondering if
you might perhaps elaborate a little bit
on what you know about these cases and
how prevalent that problem is it's hard
to know how prevalent it is but again if
five have been prosecuted here since
around 95 it means there are a lot that
we're not hearing about illegal
immigrants in this country right now are
the most vulnerable citizens they are
very wary of Authority they are very
unlikely to report abuses of the labor
code and violations of the labor code
and they are also often indebted to
their immigrants smuggler and the cases
of slavery that have unfold in Florida
been cases in which people have been
brought into this country are very much
in debt to their immigrants smuggler and
then they come here and they have to
borrow money for housing and they have
to borrow money for transportation and
they are like serfs and are treated like
serfs and are thousands of dollars in
debt and are working for no money and
the slavery cases are the most dramatic
and the most extreme but as I found in
meatpacking in this country and as I
found you know in California agriculture
the everyday abuses are astonishing
you know illegal immigrants are doing
the most difficult and most dangerous
work in this country and are getting
injured and then are being fired are
being forced to work overtime without
being paid overtime and in some cases in
California there are cases of towards
the end of the harvest they'll work a
couple of weeks and when all the crops
are harvested they simply won't be paid
and there's no way for them to complain
about it because they are in such a
vulnerable place so we really really
need to have the labor laws strictly
enforced in this country and real real
punishments made it out I mean you know
I am writing a book on prisons right now
and I think prison isn't useful for most
crimes but I think instead of putting
Tommy Chong in prison if we put some of
these growers who were abusing their
workers in prison it would have a very
it would have a very immediate effect
[Applause]
years ago we heard ross perot say that
that sucking sound was a sound of jobs
leaving america for other countries now
there's a lot of conversation about the
technical jobs leaving go into places
like india how do you think those in the
american middle class are going to
respond when the hand of the free market
really touches them well that's a very
good question but but the free market
doesn't really apply I mean for example
the the jobs these technical jobs that
are being you know quickly outsourced to
other countries those software companies
did not gain their dominance in anything
approaching the free market I mean I
believe that Microsoft's single largest
customer is the federal government and
if you look at how the internet was
created and on and on and on I mean the
government subsidy subsidizing and I
don't think it's necessarily a bad thing
to have an industrial policy that helps
certain corporations in certain sectors
but if the American people are going to
subsidize these corporations these
corporations don't have a right to
suddenly shift these jobs overseas and
certainly don't have a right to suddenly
start incorporating overseas and one of
the things I write about in the book is
you know these these I think they're
called inversion transactions in which
all these American corporations are
setting up in Bermuda or setting up
offshore simply as a way to avoid paying
taxes
Enron perfected that Enron had like 900
foreign subsidiary bank accounts that it
was shifting money through and at the
same time Enron was paying no taxes it
was getting four hundred I think four
hundred million dollars a year in
various tax breaks from the government
so once you recognize that the free
market in this perfect sense does not
exist then I think you have all kinds of
opportunity to get the government to
work not just on behalf of these
corporations but on behalf of ordinary
working people and one of the things
would be if you want to do money if you
want to do business with the US
government then you have to be much more
careful about shifting your jobs
overseas and shifting your incorporation
overseas when was the last time you had
any fast food and and also I was
wondering if you had an opinion on
Starbucks at corporation I need fast
food all the time I just don't buy it
from any of the major fast food chants I
mean my diet has not changed profoundly
since I wrote the book I don't eat
ground beef for the most part not
because I'm afraid of getting sick but
because I'm so angry at the greed of
these companies and and other people are
gonna get sick mainly children but I
still eat french fries and I still eat
all kinds of fast food but I just don't
buy it from the major fast-food chants
and I'm sorry what was the second part
of the question Starbucks I have mixed
feelings about Starbucks they they they
have pursued a very aggressive expansion
campaign in which I believe they target
independent coffee houses and have
driven so many of them out of business
and I like a world that is diverse and
has lots of different regional
restaurants and regional companies
I think that you know having us
Starbucks and every towns just fun
having 12 maybe too many what they do
that I'll give them credit for is that I
think that they have had a much more
progressive policy towards their workers
than the other fast-food you know chains
have but you know I think that that when
these brands these brands are great
until they reach a certain size and
power and then they become irritating
and destructive and so Starbucks is
alright as long as there aren't too many
of them hi I'm here as an organizer of
the demonstrations that will be taking
place November 20th and 21st against the
FTAA
and I have a lot of information for
anyone who wants to get involved with
that but I'm wondering if you could
speak to how this can be an opportunity
for Miami to take action against exactly
some of the ills and the problems that
you're speaking about and maybe against
the free trade area of the Americas
Ministerial the demonstrations will be
taking place November 19th through the
21st a whole wide variety of communities
will be here to represent those of you
who feel the same so my question is can
you speak to how this can be an
opportunity for Miami citizens to take
action against what you're talking about
in terms of free trade that's part one
in part two if you could clarify for
folks what the FTAA is because as I've
been moving around in the community
there's a shocking ignorance about what
it is and and how free is not really
free well I assume that you're talking
about the the north american free trade
agreement this is an expansion of it to
include the entire hemisphere NAFTA was
only three countries and FTA will
include 34 countries for the whole
Western Hemisphere so well I think that
for people to understand it they only
need to see what's happened since NAFTA
was passed and what's happened is
America has lost manufacturing jobs
which briefly went to Mexico and now are
being moved out of Mexico
China because these companies have no
commitment to these countries and only
their commitment to his chief of labor
as possible and you've seen the
devastation of Mexican agriculture
through the dumping of American
subsidized grains in New Mexico and I
really challenge anyone to look at
what's happened since NAFTA and what's
happened to ordinary people and say that
it's been a great benefit to the Mexican
people or the American people so when
you use that as the starting point why
would you want to expand it to include
anyone else thank you thank you I found
both of your books very interesting and
informative so please not to take this
as a criticism but something concerned
me in reefer madness the section about
marijuana and pornography I realized
that the moral acceptability of what you
cover wasn't part of your what you were
going to wasn't in the scope of your
book I guess is what I'm trying to say
but I'm it's not so much and I agree
with a lot of what you say and I found
it very interesting but it's not so much
what you say but what I think a lot of
people can read into it I think that a
lot of people can interpret your lack of
criticism or condemnation of the thing
and such as an endorsement of it even
though you explicitly say you're not
saying smoke marijuana or whatever a lot
of people can interpret it that way and
to say that well the marijuana Juana
laws are bad means marijuana is okay
isn't correct to say that while there
are lots of other bad things that are
legal
so another bit so one more bad thing
though it may not be as bad as there's
other bad things should be illegal isn't
necessarily accurate either so it's not
a criticism it's just it's it's a
nothing but I tried in this book to look
at these black markets from a business
point of view and and and with
pornography in particular when I when I
started doing that reporting there had
been an enormous amount written on
pornography Pro and against but very
little
looking at it as a commodity and looking
at as a commodity that was a business
like any other business which to me
helped explain how it went from being
this very fringe subculture into being
this very very mainstream part of you
know half a half a billion dollars a
year now and in pay-per-view pornography
I think that the conclusion that I
ultimately came to at the end of the
book and especially with pornography is
that adults should have the freedom to
decide for themselves what they want to
watch or view with certain sorts of
things that we all could agree upon
being off limits and that with certain
kinds of crimes that are victimless
crimes it's not the role of the
government to intervene and so and I
feel I mean you know I'm not gonna give
you a Nancy Reagan anti-drug speech but
I feel you know the same way about so
many of these these substances that
people take I mean people can go
skydiving in this country or bungee
jumping you know any I'm sorry no no I
and I understand that was not in the
scope of your book and I understand that
I just have seen it too often used as
and as your sort of objective
businesslike analysis use that as an
endorsement and you're talking someone
who doesn't smoke drink or use tylenol
with codeine even so you know I'm that's
all but thank you very much okay thank
you thank you agricultural labor is
really update of Steinbeck's book The
Grapes of Wrath which was written I
think 1936 and 1937 but there is one
difference the supply of Okies was not
endless the supply of immigrants coming
into this country basically from Mexico
and other South American countries is
going to be endless because if tomorrow
you made all seven or eight million
undocumented legal citizens within five
years you'd probably have another two
three million or whatever the number is
you could probably come up as a figure
as well as I and when you have a market
like that you're always going to have
unscrupulous people who will take
advantage well unless you have an abort
which is in violet you don't have a
solution to the problem which i think is
a problem well I'll give you a central
solution and and it's it's interesting
that you bring up the grapes of wrath'
which was a great great great book the
the only period of real outrage in this
country over the abuse of migrant
workers was after the greatest of Wrath
and what's interesting is the Grapes of
Wrath was about Okies about white people
being exploited in the fields and if you
look at the history of Agriculture in
California there was really only an 8
year period in which white people have
ever worked the fields and that's when
we got outraged but now the Okies were
able to work the fields in California
because all the Mexican farm workers
were sent back to Mexico around 1931 or
32 so we're very outraged about this
issue as a society when it's white
people being exploited but the reality
is people of color have been exploited
in the fields of the United States since
the inception of this country now I
would argue that it's not inevitable
and that it is preventable and here's a
quote I forgot to read that I'm going to
read to you from who I think was our
greatest president who dealt with this
issue this is a quote from Franklin
Delano Roosevelt quote no business which
depends for existence on paying less
than living wages to its workers has any
right to continue in this country by
living wages I mean more than a
subsistence level I mean the wages of a
decent income now if you have a policy
in this country which sets a minimum
wage at a level I mean right now if you
are a minimum wage you earn ten thousand
dollars a year which is a poverty wedge
ultimately I don't care what color skin
what nationality what legality a human
being is in this country if they work
they must be paid a decent wage and
that's how you solve this problem
because they all
turn ative is to have the kind of
shantytown that I saw in northern San
Diego County outside every one of these
cities because we could bring in workers
from all over the world where they're
earning $1 a week and if if there is not
a tough enforcement of our labor laws we
will become a society of very wealthy
and a society of landless poor serfs so
that's my I know that illegal migrants
are often prosecuted in jail and what
I'm wondering is are the employers of
these illegal people who are jailed are
they ever jailed and prosecute and if
not why not seems to me that that's the
natural progression the employers of
illegal immigrants not only in
agriculture but an industry are very
very rarely prosecuted and jailed I mean
we have this system that is just you
know arresting thousands and tens of
thousands of people at the border but
could be arresting a handful of chief
executives and having a much bigger
effect now the reason that they're not
arrested is the system relies on all
kinds of intermediaries that recruit and
legally employ the the migrant workers
so that you have a system of labor
contractors who are officially the
employer so that the grower is buffered
by one level legally from the employment
of these workers and you'll find again
and again the growers saying I I'm
shocked to hear illegals were employed
in my field and I'm not employing them I
hired this labor contractor to bring in
workers and it's his business you find
that in the janitorial trade I mean
Walmart is being investigated right now
but it has the excuse of saying well we
didn't hire these illegals to work seven
days a week at our stores it was the
contractor we hired to bring in janitors
who did so they're the the employers
and the growers are very clever using
legal mechanisms to avoid prosecution it
seems to me that the government's being
so hypocritical because if they really
did not want these illegal alien illegal
immigrants the illegal migrants to come
into this country if they went and
prosecuted and fined them find the
employers very highly the employers
would not hire them they certainly would
not want to hire illegal people I think
our victim and have to pay let's say ten
thousand dollars a week for Oh for every
illegal migrant there are many employers
who are innocently employing illegal
immigrants and are not deliberately
doing it there are some who are
systematically recruiting them and
exploiting them and those employers
should be prosecuted and I think that
would have a huge huge effect I'm sorry
it's time for one more question
in Fast Food Nation you recommend it
that if the readers were outraged and
people were outraged with the conduct of
fast-food companies we shouldn't support
them and not to go and purchase their
foods what do you recommend for outrage
for everything you've just spoken about
what can we do well I think if you care
about the exploitation of the weakest
poorest Americans by far
then you will support for example the
United Farm Workers Union in California
is mounting a strawberry campaign and
they're asking for an extra nickel per
pint of strawberries to go to the
workers which would have a huge impact
and here in Florida the coalition of
Immokalee Workers is staging a
nationwide boycott of Taco Bell Taco
Bell is purchasing a great many tomatoes
from Florida and that's where a lot of
the slavery cases have occurred and the
tomato pickers of Florida are not asking
for a socialist revolution they're
asking for an extra penny per pound of
tomatoes and I think that's something
that's achievable so there are all kinds
of really good groups who are working on
these issues who need your support and
thank you very much
[Applause]
we are halfway through our live coverage
chair at the book a Miami Book Fair
International and just heard from Eric
Schlosser the author of fast trans
nation from 2001 and reefer madness went
on which he appeared for book notes on
earlier this year it was published
earlier this year and we got a lot more
coming up again about halfway through
we're gonna go till 6 p.m.